March 2010 a satellite image taken over
Russia reveals something extraordinary a
massive spiral of a hundred and eight
perfect circles the weirdest aspect of
this image is the change in the size of
these circles the image is captured over
southern Siberia on the frozen waters of
Lake Baikal it's one of the most remote
areas in the world during the Soviet era
Westerners were banned from visiting
here the circular features certainly
don't make me think of an ice-covered
lake they don't seem like they belong
but no idea why these are here the
circles forming the spiral range from
one-and-a-half feet to several miles in
diameter in total they cover 18 square
miles this is snow and you can see the
clear ice but then there's these
mysterious circles and that's the thing
that is most striking
to see this elaborative pattern is
something that we generally don't find
in large-scale patterns of the earth
it's a little too symmetrical from my
taste that it tells me that what we're
looking at is really hard to make in
nature but might be more the result of
something that man has done for someone
to make these circles they would have to
go out on the ice in temperatures of
minus 40 degrees Fahrenheit
someone made a real effort to create
this but why
[Music]
one man may have the answer to the
mystery artist Jim Donovan is famous for
his innate ability to form large perfect
circles I can make a pretty perfect
circle all the way to the clip and it
would take me 13 minutes and I would
arrive at the same place is from years
and years of experience and the
completion of a circles is very powerful
in 2010 the maverick artist brave the
Siberian wilderness to fulfill a dream
I wanted to make the world's biggest
drawing and like Baikal is the best
place to do it
I made a spiral of circles which grew in
a ratio 108 circles the first circle is
the size of dinner plate to get larger
and larger and larger they spiral and
the largest circle is almost 10 miles in
circumference it's as big as a city
over fifteen days and nights den 'van
and a team of artists carved the complex
geometric spiral on to the lake ice
that's a lot of work shoveling ice in
sub-zero temperatures
I guess suffering for your art is
worthwhile especially if it can be seen
from space
you